[Música]
o que é o amor
a primeira vez que o fiz essa pergunta
era assim na escola me chamavam de feio
esquisito quatro olho louco louco porque
eu pedi pra a julia falar com ana
carolina que era menina mais bonita da
escola que eu
o menino mais esquisito gostava dela
fiquei atrás da porta pra escutar e vai
que né
a júlia falou com aninha daniel e que
gosta de você e aí respondeu ou e que é
feio né
aí naquele dia eu aprendi que você nunca
deve escutar conversa dos outros
fui embora cheguei em casa minha mãe
estava na sala sentado no sofá e eu
deitei no colo dela e comecei a chorar e
aí minha mãe olhou assustada e perguntou
meu filho porque você tá chorando eu
olhei pra minha mãe perguntei mãe
será que algum dia alguma garota vai
gostar de mim ea minha mãe começou a
chorar
foi o efeito reverso passou um tempo meu
pai chegou viu aquela cena duas caras
chada e ele perguntou por que estão
chorando e aí eu olhei pra ele mas sei
lá
ele fez uma cara e falou ok minha
família é louca ea gente começou a rir e
minha mãe me abraçou e falou com
confiança
meus pais tinha essa mania de responder
tudo de forma enigmática
sempre soltava o enigma e se vira
claro que com a qualidade não fazia
idéia de que essa palavra
eu fui entender começar a entender isso
quando eu completei 15 anos me apaixonei
pela minha vizinha duda
o dia teve uma festa dançante e as
meninas ficavam sentada esperando os
meninos chamaram pra dançar
naquele dia eu aprendi que nunca deve se
misturar bebida eu misturei coca com
sukita
fiquei doido e comecei a andar em
direção à duda e meus amigos do meu lado
e pensar que isso você está envolta aqui
e tá doida eu fui quando eu parei na
frente dela
os homens que estão aqui vão entender
quando um cara gosta muito de uma menina
ele treme todo eu estava igual àqueles
bonecão do posto sabe que vai ficar em
falta sim e aí estava naquela fase
adolescente que lucra voz às vezes saía
grave ou aguda crescer sempre estava com
uma bola de algodão na garganta e eu
falei com a duda saiu algo parecido com
isso e já estava projetando a minha fuga
pra viver na rua mendigo solitário e ela
respondeu sim e aí eu falei como é que é
ela repetiu sim e eu não sabia o que
fazer porque eu nunca tinha chegado até
ali aquela parte era nova para mim eu já
tinha recebido tanto não na vida que eu
nem sabia que uma menina sabia falar
assim
e aí ela levantou me abraçou e começou a
tocar novembro em do ganso ea gente
dançou
quando acabou a música ela se afastou e
eu não fazia idéia do que fazer quando
ela ficou parado na minha frente eu
estava no ensino médio só sabe jogar
bola tomar coca-cola e ficar na frente
da tv
veneno cívica e aí só que aí vem uma voz
do alencar e foi o cinema com a voz com
é que tudo confiança confiança
e aí eu fui esse foi meu primeiro beijo
a coisa mais esquisita e doce que eu já
fiz na minha vida há dúvidas o rio daqui
até aqui o sorriso fazer assim e ela me
abraçou e a gente começou a dançar sem
música eu adoro a gente namorou por
muito tempo até completar 18 anos de
idade oficial de idiotice masculina
todo mundo ficava na minha carteira
carro mulherada e um dia eu chamei a
duda e falhou tudo quero terminar
e aí ela foi porque eu falhar porque eu
quero conhecer outras meninas para saber
se é a mulher da minha vida né
e aí ela segurou minha mão olhou no meu
olho e falou que pena aí que eu soube
desde o primeiro dia que você era um
garoto da minha vida
ela foi embora eu chorei com cinco horas
seguidas
cheguei em casa e contei para o meu pai
e meu pai só falou escolhas
eu passei muito tempo sem entender
aquilo obviamente e muito tempo sem
encontrar ninguém até encontrar um novo
amor
um dia essa menina veio e falou e que eu
quero terminar eu falei porque o amor
acabou e ela falou não o amor não acabou
mas não é esse amor que eu quero e eu
falei com amor sequer
e aí ela falou eu quero é jogar de um
precipício sem saber se vai ter alguém
para me segurar
eu falei pois é hora de poema que está
terminando comigo é o senhor para esse
aspecto e ela começou a rir fosse demais
e me abraçou e foi embora
foi gente eu sou de mais um poema eo
término
voltei pra casa meu pai veio falar
comigo final hoje não aconselha
hoje eu quero falar com minha mãe e
cheguei comecei contato eu tava estava
sofrendo e chorando contando pra ela e
quando cheguei na parte do poema e
recitar o poema a minha mãe abriu um
sorriso daqui até aqui eu fui mais tá de
brincadeira
e aí a única coisa que ela falou foi
esperança e é com essa palavra que
começa a história que mudou
completamente a minha vida e me trouxe
até aqui era junho de 2013
minha namorada terminou comigo um pouco
antes do dia dos namorados eu saí do
carro dela igual a us 1 bi ea única
coisa que vi na minha cabeça era a voz
dizendo eu amo você chega em casa com
tempo meu pai foi pai porque terminou
comigo tem amor aqui dentro eu sei que
tem amor dentro dela e meu pai falou meu
filho quando alguém entra na sua vida
depois de um tempo vai embora
pode ser qualquer coisa menos amor
construir uma nova história
eu falei pai mas como é que começa isso
quem for não se preocupe
todo começo vem de um final e aquilo
bagunçou minha cabeça porque eu comecei
a lembrar que todos meus amores começar
porque um terminou eu só entrei no
emprego porque a faculdade terminou aqui
de um loop infinito e quando estava
começando a ficar bem
uma semana depois meu pai foi
diagnosticado quando essa rádio
degenerativa queria matá-lo em 90 dias
na hora que recebeu o diagnóstico e
minha mãe começamos a chorar xingar tudo
gritar meu pai à nossa frente parado
normal sereno e eu comecei a me xingar
meu pai eu fui porque não tá chorando
porque não tá chorando e ele falou olha
pra mim o filho ea única coisa que eu
pensava é como é que eu vou olhar para a
pessoa que eu mais amo no mundo sabendo
que ela vai morrer eu não consegui olhar
e meu pai me segurou olha pra mim e eu
olhei ele falou se você soubesse que
hoje é o último dia de sua vida ia
passar e chorando e aí minha mãe ficamos
parado eu falei 'pai você não pode
morrer
ele foi meu filho todo mundo vai morrer
eu falei 'pai meses
todo mundo vai morrer ea gente o que a
gente vai fazer
ele só respondeu viver e foi isso que
ele foi fazer a gente foi viver
voltamos a fazer coisas simples como
almoçar juntos e ao cinema e jantar
junto até que a doença começou a tentar
impedir meu pai de viver e chegou a
capacidade de falar eu comprei um ipad
entreguei pra ele e ele começou a
escrever uma pergunta pra mim e pra
minha mãe eu peguei o ipad e comecei a
escrever
entreguei a minha mãe ea minha mãe
começou a escrever meu pai começou a
chorar porque ele percebeu que a gente
reviver aquilo com eles se não falava a
gente não falava a gente não ia
abandonar e aquelas conversas giraram
lições de vida porque eu não converso
sobre o amor e sobre os inúmeros fóruns
que eu tomava continuo tomando e sobre o
amor que ele tinha com a minha mãe eu
peguei aquela conversa que viraram
textos e publica no blog e viralizou na
internet milhões de pessoas criam os
textos várias editoras do país me
procuraram para publicar um livro
eu nem sabia que meu pai escrevi e que o
sonho dele era publicar um livro chega
em casa correndo falei para não publicar
um livro e ele começou a chorar
tremei gás go ocorrido a minha mamãe
papai tá passando mal e minha mãe veio
correndo
eu peguei o ipad entreguei pra ele e ele
escreveu
será que vai dar tempo e aí eu saí
correndo desesperado pela editora e
falei eu não quero dinheiro quero nada
eu só quero que o livro saiu mais rápido
possível eu pai poder ver isso
eles falaram que tem todos os textos foi
tem então manda agora voltei pra casa
correndo
falei para nós tem que mandar o texto
agora será que alguma coisa
ele falou que era que o último texto
seja o meu pai tá bom qual é o texto
ele falou eu acabei de escrever mas é
preciso me prometeu uma coisa eu falei o
que foi
você só pode ler depois que eu morrer eu
falei pai como as ímpar e eu falei pra
ele tá bom então você tem que prometer
uma coisa e eles querem o que você não
pode morrer
e aí meu pai cumprimos a promessa
a gente lançou o nosso livro faça amor
não faça jogo
mais de 400 pessoas no orçamento eu meu
pai minha mãe minha sobrinha
o livro best seller no país só que aí é
doença tentou impedir meu pai de viver e
colocou e sua capacidade de andar e
colocou na cadeira de rodas e agora a
gente rodas que a gente ia fazer meu pai
amava viajar a gente transformou a
cadeira no avião e todo dia pela manhã a
gente descia pela nossa pista de
decolagem fazer um plano de vôo
eu separei um dia pra vocês
eu não lembro se digitar pela nova
zelândia foram muitas viagens e sempre
que a gente terminava pousava eu pegava
o ipad entrava no país que a gente tava
ele ficava vendo as imagens estava
cultura do país e tudo meu pai há mais
de 30 anos e toda sexta feira com dois
irmãos na mesma pizzaria ele continue no
de cadeira de rodas
só que a doença tentou impedir meu pai
de viver e tirou a capacidade de comer e
aí os irmãos deles meus filhos começaram
em casa toda sexta feira e falou que a
pizzaria não tinha graça e meu pai e
eles ficavam rindo dando risada e meu
pai começou a chorar quando eles fizeram
isso porque ele viu que os irmãos dele
não ia abandonar ele e não abandonar o
forno em casa toda sexta feira é o
último dia de vida do meu pai meu pai
ele formou em ouro preto minas gerais e
ele tinha três amigos quando eles
formaram isso combinaram que de cinco em
cinco anos eles vão se ver
naquele ano o pai está muito debilitado
e não conseguiu ir
os três amigos dele cada formando tem
uma foto pregada na república
os três amigos pegaram as fotos 4 pegar
a estrada chegar lá em casa surpresa
entregar as fotos no quarto do meu pai
me falaram a nossa república é a sua
casa
meu pai começou a chorar e todo mundo
começou a chorar porque ele viu que os
amigos dele não ia abandonar e não
abandonar trocar os 55 anos para um mês
eles vão lá e fazem uma [ __ ] nova festa
república no dia 2 de julho de 2015
os meus pais completavam 46 anos casado
todo aniversário de casamento os meus
pais fazem isso aqui ó
eles dançavam naquele ano o meu pai não
conseguia ficar em pé
e aí a minha mãe falou duas cadeiras de
rodas
eu falei porque mãe que quer fazer ela
respondeu vou fazer o seu pai faria por
mim eu busquei a cadeira de rodas e
quando eu voltei para o quarto a minha
mãe estava abraçada com meu pai na cama
eu cheguei perto para ajudar ela for não
precisa e ela começou a testar meu pai
da cama
fazendo uma força e meu pai não tinha
força não sei de onde ele tirou a última
força que o filho fazer na vida ea minha
mãe conseguiu colocar na cadeira de
rodas ela colocou uma música e ajoelhou
lado dele e começou a fazer a cadeira
jirau e os dois começaram a dançar
meu pai chorar e ao mesmo tempo e foi a
cena mais bonita que já vi na minha vida
inteira
quando acabou a dança
meu pai eu entreguei o ipad com o meu
pai e ele escreveu eu tenho um último
sonho e eu perguntei qual que é pai
ele escreveu quero ver o mar pela última
vez
foi então a gente vai eu fui muito
criticado muita gente falou que eu era
louco porque e levar uma pessoa que não
falava não combinam fazia nada pra praia
querem aproveitar nada é uma coisa que
passava na minha cabeça era talvez o
amor seja isso fazer loucuras fazer um
improvável o impossível virar possível e
eu separei três momentos da viagem para
vocês verem o início o meio eo fim
quando este voltou da viagem
meu pai estava muito debilitado ele
pegou o ipad que começou a escrever meu
filho eu estou sentindo muita dor
a minha mão tremia muito e eu não sei
até quando vou conseguir escrever
a gente precisa criar uma nova forma de
comunicar se a pescar uma vez e assim
duas é não e 3d e eu te amo no dia 23 de
agosto de 2015
o meu pai faleceu os médicos têm andado
90 dias
meu pai viveu por mais de mil 95 eu
resolvi contar um pouco dessa história
aqui porque eu vejo o mundo do setor
senão complica demais as coisas ficam
alguém que faz isso que te dê aquilo e
todas essas regras e exigências são
criadas pela cabeça
o amor é criada que tenha no coração o
resto todo é ilusão
a sociedade exigindo demais estratos
sociais bens materiais pedindo que os
pais coloquem os filhos nas melhores
escolas nas escolas mais caras que
estuda em três línguas que as esposas
seja os melhores da mãe sejam bem
sucedidas e eu queria dizer para todos
vocês que tudo isso não significa nada a
única coisa que a pessoa bem mais
valioso que vocês têm podem dar para
alguém que você ama é o seu tempo aquele
tempo que a pessoa dentro no seu colo
você fala vai ficar tudo bem a pessoa
que você ama só precisa que você passa
pela confiança que esteja ao lado dela
nas suas escolhas e que principalmente
de a essa esperança recebeu o primeiro
pedido deu seu tempo para a pessoa que
você ama
muita gente acha que é fácil eu pedia
isso porque acha que a minha relação com
o meu pai é perfeita e não existe nada
perfeito no mundo e meu pai eram cheios
de fez nós seres humanos somos cheios de
efeitos
quantas vezes meu pai entrou no meu
quarto eu falei pai me deixe passar
tocando guitarra time deixe passar o
jogo videogame e sabe que ele fazia ele
sorria eu tratava ele mal ele sorrir
ele batia minha raiva e paciência com
amor e foi isso que ele me ensinou
quando alguém que a gente ama nos tratar
mal em vez de tratá la mal de volta deu
seu amor porque o amor é a única forma
capaz de transformar o mundo e as
pessoas
o meu pai me transformou o que me salvou
ele nunca desistiu de mim e esse é meu
último pedido nunca desista da pessoa
que você ama e agora você deve tá
querendo saber o que é o amor acreditar
e seu enigma a forma mais bonita que eu
aprendi a deixar um pouco do meu amor
dentro de todos vocês que estão aqui
fica com deus obrigado
[Aplausos]